in Washington DC chaos erupts as a jtf
helicopter is shot down by the outcasts
causing it to crash through the roof of
the Mexican embassy agents are swiftly
assigned to locate the wreckage rescue
the pilot and secure the supplies time
is of the essence as the outcasts are
moving in eager to claim the spoils for
themselves
[Music]
with a sense of urgency the agents
embarked on their mission their first
challenge was to obtain level 1 security
clearance ensuring access to the
restricted areas within the building
maneuvering through the debris they
navigated through the darkened hallways
keeping on full alert
as they are centered towards the
ambassador's office the agents faced
numerous Outcast forces
biting through they would eventually
obtain level 2 security clearance
routing them entry to the ambassador's
office
there they were confronted by explosives
that have been rigged by the outcasts
working quickly the agents were able to
secure and neutralize the threat
working the way through the atrium they
began to see some of the damage caused
by the helicopter's impact
while continuing to push forward towards
the crash site the agents are met with
wave after wave of outcasts
but they fought through and eventually
would meet up with the injured pilot
John yezzy
miraculously he had survived the crash
but this would now add another layer of
complexity to this already dangerous
situation
determined to claim the facility the
outcasts kept pushing through agents
would need to continue holding them off
while also making sure that John Yazi is
safe and extracted from the building
I know we've had our differences in the
past but this isn't about immigration
policy this is about quarantine
some of these isolated communities have
never been exposed to the measles or
MRSA even if your people aren't infected
they could still be a threat I want to
work with you but I need assurances that
we won't accidentally unleash a
secondary outbreak
have Sarasota testing facilities if the
refugees Clear Medical
I'll see what I can do
in a tense conversation between the
Mexican ambassador and what is likely to
be a representative of the US government
the Ambassador acknowledges the
historical differences they've had
perhaps related to immigration policies
but emphasizes that the current
situation should be viewed in a
different light
the Ambassador highlights the potential
risks posed by isolated communities who
have not been exposed to diseases like
this
despite their concerns the Ambassador
expresses a willingness to collaborate
and find a solution
nice watch yeah here's two
glad to see you're still orange Andy
isn't it you came up with anybody yet
really it's hard to tell who you can
trust these days
yeah
to be honest I never really thought
would be activated it strikes were nice
though
you got a name or do you just want to be
called Agent sorry yeah Espinoza
Kelso try not to me over Espinoza
you good still got all your parts
yeah I'm fine probably need some new
armor but nothing penetrated
God bless the bulletproof hoodie right
thanks for having my back
you don't have to thank me
I know
well I guess I should be going
it's been fun working with you yeah
we make a pretty great team
yeah we kind of do
maybe we could keep working together
nothing in the manual says we can't
do you want to be my partner Kelso
sure
just friends though
Kelso and agent Espinoza met quite early
on after the outbreak but it was late
enough that they were both skeptical
about each other
this Paints the picture of what it was
like among the division ranks after so
many of the first waves started going
rogue they couldn't even trust each
other
however maybe reluctantly at first they
began to work with each other and would
grow a tight Bond
you've got family down in Mexico I'm
sure they take you in well I got family
here too they may not be blood but
they're family
and they need to trust her to have their
back and who's going to have yours Kelso
she's too stubborn and crazy to let me
die I'll be fine
back at the Mexican embassy the
Ambassador tells agent Espinoza that he
is a way out that he doesn't need to
stay in the U.S he is family back in
Mexico
but Espinoza loyal to his duty as a
division agent insists that he must stay
to carry out his mission and that Kelso
will do her best to keep him safe
for those of you who don't remember we
would catch up with agent Espinoza later
on at the Jefferson Trade Center
he was assigned to the mission to
reactivate the Isaac substation that was
stored underneath the building
unfortunately he would be captured by
hyena leader coyote hello
is this the division
looking for someone who is this how are
you on this channel one of yours gave me
a real nice wristwatch
he's right here wanna talk to him
if you want him back we can make a deal
you back off we'll deliver him unharmed
mostly
they'll keep him alive they aren't
stupid just find that hyena piece of
and waste her
coyote contacted the division agents via
espinoza's watch and told them that she
had the agent and warned that if they
didn't leave the compound they would
kill Espinoza
but Kelso attempted to call her Bluff
she told the agents to proceed through
the Trade Center believing that coyote
wouldn't be stupid enough to harm him
however the division agents would soon
meet with the hyena leader in the
courtyard and there they watched as
coyote took agent Espinoza to the top of
a balcony before shooting him with his
sidearm Point Blank it was worth three
stories to the ground floor where he was
killed on impact
damn it Kelso
to be fair this isn't news to us we
learned if this event in the first
playthrough of the story where kelsu was
just a little bit too blase about the
situation a fellow agent was in
however from this we learned Kelso and
Espinoza were actually quite close he
even considered her as family
I don't know I just find this really
disappointing not just another agent but
someone she's close to and she still
didn't bat an eye and told the agents to
run on him regardless of the threats to
espinoza's life
why the rush we could have caught up
with coyote later
realistically coyote could have killed
him regardless of what we did but there
was still a chance there
I realized that slowing down and taking
the time to assess the situation really
isn't Kelso's strong suit but this is
just another situation where Kelso has
acted just a little bit too recklessly
like there is more to it
I try really hard to like and Trust
Kelso especially since the last few
times I've ripped into her on social
media there is at least one developer
that comes to her defense which makes me
think she isn't actually meant to seem
as dodgy as she comes across
there is a big divide in the community
between those who trust her and those
who don't
and I probably need to take a little bit
of responsibility for that but
intentional or not there are just so
many red flags
I was hoping to get this out before
season 1 was released because of the
John Yazi Rescue It would have led in
nicely
but you know real life stuff has been
keeping me a little busier than usual
lately
anyway I hope you've enjoyed this thank
you once again for watching these videos
and extremist malice extreme remedia
[Music]
[Applause]